حديث عن ابرز الاحداث في لبنان لعام 2022
منضم الينا من شمال لبنان الزميله
رينادويهي مراسله صباح العربيه رينا اهلا
بك تغطيتك خلال كل هذه السنه كانت مميزه
بتقريرك الجميله وليست الجميله حديثينا عن
احداث لبنان ريما
[موسيقى]
نعم يودعه لبنان
والسياسيه والماليه وربما يدخل يعني
بالعام 2023 دون رئيسنا للجمهوريه دون
حكومه وفضل انهيار مستمر لليره ولكن مع
ذلك بكثير من الامل هذا الامل الذي انعكس
روما ازمه الكهرباء المستمره اضواء وزينه
في كافه المناطق اللبنانيه ان اليوم على
ضفاف بحيره نشعي حيث يعني تعدوا مركز
لانشطه ثقافيه همم تنشر كثيرا من الفرح في
ابناء هذه المنطقه هنا تقوم وسط ضفاف هذه
البحيره كما ترون خلف شجره ميلاديه من
عبوات البلاستيكيه كثيره تحمل توقيع
لبنانيه ادخلت لبنان الى موسوعه غينيس همم
عده مرات وفيها يعني رساله الى اهميه همم
الى اطفاء الفرحه اولا واهميه التشجيع على
اعاده التدوير وليس بعيدا من هنا وعلى طول
الخط الساحلي من الشمال الى بيروت مرورا
بشكه والبترون وجبال وصولا الى وصفه
المدينه اسواق الميلاديه والاضواء وزينه
ولو بمبادرات خاصه في في معظم الاحيان الا
ان وصل عاصمه كان لافتا هذا العام وصل
العاصمه الذي تحول الى مكان مهجور بعد
انفجار الرابع من اب عاد اليه الكثير من
رونقه عاد مقصدا لكثير من السياح ولكثير
من المغتربين الذين يعول عليهم لبنان
وضخ العمله الصعبه هؤلاء المغتربون الذين
يعني قصدوا لبنان للمعايده مع اهلهم ول-
اا دعم ابنائهم وصله كل الازمات الكثيره
التي يعيشها لبنان هذه الازمات التي افرزت
اشكالا كبيره من التعاضد الاجتماعي الذي
يتميز فيه لبنان فليس من فتره قليله مثلا
اقيم ماراثون ميلادي رقد فيه اكثر من 500
شخص دائما مركز سرطان الاطفال في لبنان
على ازمه مستمر بالدواء وبحليب الاطفال
وبكل ذلك ولكن همم يبقى على موعد همم كبير
بامل افضل بمحاولات اللي انعاش هذا البلد
ولو الى حين
شكرا جزيلا دائما ريناوي
ظن راح اختي خطوه بمجال شغلي خطوه جريئه
خليني اقول
يعني
ما بدي شيء هذا احلى حلم عندك
كمان وعدم القلق والمستقبل الي بيقلق كثير
بلبنان انه ما يكون في هذا القلق بكون
احسن من قبل ان شاء الله ويتحسن وضع البلد